The first trailer for Marvel's The Avengers:
Infinity War has finally dropped, and it's
as much of a doozy as fans might've expected.
Not only do we finally see the many new subsets
of superheroes come together with the OG Avengers,
but Thanos has finally decided to step down
from his space throne and take a shot at gathering
those Infinity Stones.
And, from the looks of this trailer, he's
off to a good start.
Let's take a look at some of the finer details
you might've missed in the trailer for Avengers:
Infinity War.
Loki's betrayal
The events of Thor: Ragnarok might've brought
Thor and Loki to a cheeky detente, but it
was just a matter of time before brother dearest
betrayed that newly-earned trust.
This new trailer shows Loki handing over the
Tesseract to someone who is probably Thanos
or one of his minions.
And if that isn't bad enough, it also shows
him stepping over a bunch of bodies to do
so.
Could that giant ship that arrived in the
bleak mid-credits scene after Ragnarok truly
have heralded Thanos' arrival?
And if so, will it mean the destruction of
the remaining Asgardians?
Thor does seem pretty broken up in the glimpses
we get of him here.
He's sporting a patch to conceal the damage
Hela did to his eye in Ragnarok, and he seems
to be trying to fight something well above
his pay grade by pushing against the levers
on some massive machine.
He's later shown looking through a spaceship
window, which might be on the Guardians' Milano.
And when he does finally meet Star-Lord and
his alien crew, Thor seems lonelier and more
contemptuous than ever.
If our hunch is right about Loki, it's not
hard to guess why Thor would be in such a
bad mood.
A new villain?
There are two flashes in the Avengers: Infinity
War trailer that point to a new villain.
In one, Captain America, all decked out in
black and bearded, is shown tussling with
someone who looks a lot like Proxima Midnight,
a member of Thanos' Black Order.
Then, we see poor Vision having his head zapped
by a golden staff that looks an awful lot
like the one owned by Corvus Glaive in the
comics.
This grim reaper-esque villain is a faithful
servant of Thanos, a member of his Black Order,
and is known for having a magical connection
to his glaive's blade, which appears to do
his terrible bidding against Vision here.
Since Thanos is on a mission to collect Infinity
Stones—and Vision possesses the Mind Stone—we
might be looking at the first member of his
new hit squad here, even if we barely see
his face.
Spidey's new digs
It looks like Spider-Man plays a big part
in trying to shut down the portal … or whatever
that device that's hanging over the city will
be called.
And he'll be doing so in his fancy new "Iron
Spider" suit—and that's not the only thing
that's new about Spider-Man in this movie.
He's also shown on a school bus experiencing
his spider-sense in the form of raised arm
hair, which alerts him to the fact that the
city's just been invaded by the looming sky
ring of doom.
Wakanda here we come
Avengers: Infinity War won't be the first
film to make landfall in Wakanda, of course,
since we first saw the country in Civil War's
mid-credits scene.
Black Panther's release date precedes the
Infinity War by several months as well.
But it does look like the gang will recruit
T'Challa and Okoye to join their superhero
squad—there are several glimpses of Wakanda
throughout the trailer, including one big
battle that'll feature Captain America, the
Winter Soldier, the Black Widow, Hulk, and
more.
Guess Bruce isn't having trouble transitioning
back and forth into Hulk the way he feared
he might be in Thor: Ragnarok.
Hand-to-hand
Although Thanos has been a pretty hands-off
kind of space villain until now, he decided
in the mid-credits scene for Avengers: Age
of Ultron that he was going to take matters
into his own hands before gloving up with
the then-unjeweled Infinity Gauntlet.
And it looks like he's going to make good
on that promise in Avengers: Infinity War,
because he's shown personally bringing the
pain to some of our heroes.
Chief among his victims is Spider-Man who
seems to take quite a beating from our intergalactic
baddie.
Of course, the final showdown will probably
be a little more spectacular than either of
these clips, but it's still clearly very personal
for Thanos right now.
Speaking of which …
Thanos has stones
Before this movie, it wasn't clear that Thanos
would have any Infinity Stones to add to his
Gauntlet, or whether he'd even gotten the
real Gauntlet this time.
As expected, though, the fact that it's on
his left hand now shows that it is not only
the real deal, but he's been able to add at
least two stones to it.
The first stone is purple, which seems to
indicate that he's retrieved the Power Stone
Ronan tried to keep for himself in Guardians
of the Galaxy, but which ended up securely
at Nova Corps headquarters.
The second is blue, which probably means it's
the Space Stone Loki is shown passing along
earlier.
We don't know if he'll be able to gather the
yellow Mind Stone from Vision, or the green
Time Stone from Doctor Strange … but he's
still farther along in his quest than many
fans might've expected by now.
There was a leaked teaser image in 2014 that
indicated Thanos would eventually gather all
of the stones at some point, but it's not
clear whether that'll happen in this movie,
or in Avengers Four, which is due in 2019.
One thing we do know is that it'll all add
up to a heck of a fight for our heroes—one
that's destined to end in what Marvel chief
Kevin Feige has described as "a finale" for
the MCU as we know it.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!